I haven't noticed any great groundswell
of affection for Washington and that's
good it's Kennedy for recent TV sitting
with Andrew Ferguson and his beautiful
Nick mansion here in Virginia Andrew is
a longtime writer for the Weekly
Standard he's also the author of two
books crazy you and land of Lincoln and
you have written a great piece for Time
magazine about the extraordinary wealth
in Washington DC so why is there so much
money in DC right now what's few because
it's being taken from the rest of the
country median average income I think is
70% higher than the national average Wow
and it's basically a parasitic economy
it's it sucks up the money from the rest
of the country and then puts people to
work here and a lot of the money at
least the people who are benefiting from
it are private contractors they're their
government contractors right and you
explain it as the government just
changing clothes right well basically
because the government is a political
matter can only grow it's such and such
a rate they let it grow in disguise the
growth by hiring private contractors so
it's often happens now that you'll have
contractors who do nothing but get hired
by government contracts to help them get
government contracts so huge amounts of
taxpayer money are going to these
private firms that essentially run the
government for the government so it's
it's it's an odd kind of situation where
the outsiders actually know more about
how the government works than the
insiders do the the sort of deceptive
thing is people in Washington say well
you know the government workforce really
hasn't expanded that much you know and
our budgets are we're really working
under budget constraints well that's
simply because they've just sort of
outsourced to everything the power is
still here in Washington I live in Los
Angeles where we're still feeling the
recession very much and the ill effects
of bad government and big deficits when
are we gonna see this wealth out west oh
well when we decide to send you some
what's happened here there was a
recession here in
in the Washington area but it was much
shallower and the recovery was much
quicker than it was in the rest of the
country for example here in Arlington
where I live the median house prices
took a dip but now they're backed up to
their peak where they were in 2007
before the crash we get to print money
and we also get to take it from the rest
of the country at the point of a gun
for this kind of a boom in this sort of
new upper class this uber Washington
class for example environmentalism is
extremely important so you go around
town and there are wars against the
private automobile you see bike share
rental racks all over the place and zip
cars which are cars you can rent by the
hour so you don't actually have to sully
your hands by owning an automobile yeah
what that basically means is that you
have a sensibility the regulators of the
economy who don't understand the economy
so let's say you're in Pennsylvania in
western Pennsylvania fracking comes
along for natural gas this is a promise
of a better life this is a way of
getting out of the hole that the economy
is in here it's an abomination fracking
is a violation of everything that's the
environment well where it is the
fracking actually get regulated it gets
regulated here by people who have no
understanding of the kinds of challenges
that are being faced by the rest of the
country so there's hypocrisy and
disconnect in Washington oh my god I
can't believe it
stop the presses yeah but you know as I
say it's there is a serious side to it
because I think the the the regulatory
state is so ill-equipped to respond to
the needs of the rest of the country
that the country suffers as a result of
this disconnection I the rest of the
country really isn't cheering for
Washington DC are they I haven't noticed
any great groundswell of affection for
Washington and that's good I mean that's
a very good American way to look at
things people should be always skeptical
of power and concentrations of power
what's happened I think over the last 40
years is that the concentrations of
power in Washington have really started
to separate the capital from the rest
country and that's what's new great
article in Time magazine everyone should
read it to see what's going on in DC and
if only you lived here and made as much
money come on down we're happy to have
you for reason TV I'm Kennedy thank you
very much Andy Ferguson thank you for
having me